la amistad con marruecos enemistad con
argelia es la actual situación de españa
estamos en estos momentos
analizando
exactamente las implicaciones de esa
medida y dar la respuesta adecuada a
serena
constructiva pero también firme en la
defensa de los intereses de españa
palabras en respuesta a la suspensión de
argelia el miércoles del tratado de
amistad buena vecindad y cooperación con
españa lo que significa la congelación
del comercio exterior entre ambos países
después de 20 años de relaciones las
autoridades españolas emprendieron una
campaña para justificar la posición que
adoptaron sobre el sáhara occidental'
una violación de sus obligaciones
legales morales y políticas sin embargo
desde el gobierno de españa confían en
que no esté en riesgo el suministro de
gas de uno de sus principales
proveedores la medida afecta para nuevos
contratos pero es que además las
relaciones entre españa y argelia lo que
respecta a son relaciones contractuales
entre compañías privadas contratos que
en principio cuentan con una vigencia de
por lo menos 10 años la unión europea se
mostró extremadamente preocupada ya que
consideran argelia un socio clave para
la estabilidad de la región
sin embargo argelia ha respondido así al
presidente del gobierno de españa pedro
sánchez el miércoles en el congreso
había defendido la posición sobre el
sáhara occidental' para la que acepta
una autonomía como propone marruecos un
movimiento contrario a los intereses de
argelia principal aliado del frente
polisario el movimiento de liberación
nacional del sáhara occidental'